so first of all I I love the movie but
what did you like about it it was just
funny it was so heartfelt it was like
it's a good movie that I can like watch
with my parents and it's yeah I'm always
like looking for those kinds of movies
that like everybody can agree on yeah I
agree I think that you know that what
that it's not manufactured yes you know
it's not like some sort of right like a
template like every other movie and the
oh no way you see that go okay I get it
like takes you a place you don't think
you're gonna go there and it takes you
there and I thought it was just
absolutely delightful right it was they
love how this structures
almost even like the stopping at the
plane and right yeah yeah it was almost
like more about you know the
relationship with the dad than even you
know his girlfriend yeah we haven't seen
that rom-com the rom-com between a dad
and the son yeah yeah yeah so Brett I
got like a kick out of your character
because he completely reminds me of
somebody one of my closest friends who
was my roommate in college like he was
kind of from a wealthy family and then
he was like I'm a socialist and like no
one would like you know take him
seriously and just like some of you are
like one-liners I was wondering because
uh Laura was talking about improv how
much was that also figures like how much
improv was you know involved on set
there was a lot of improv I yeah I but
um yeah right it was both yeah we did
what was written I guess it was always
the freedom to like also yeah yeah so
there was a lot of collaboration on this
app which was awesome awesome yeah so
the other thing is because it's like I
always find it amusing that you know
Sebastian got De Niro to play his dad
and I always like talking with people
about like oh who do you want like play
your you know parent in a movie so I
already know you play you know their
parent but if you were to cast like your
actual like one of your parents in a
movie with you yeah who would you pick
uh I would go with
um Brian Dennehy yeah yeah Billy Bob
Thornton for my dad yeah shaved head oh
boy my dad who I don't know I got no
answer no never mind I'll think about it
yeah
okay how are you doing pretty good yeah
I'm fine got it yet no hold on
so how did you come in contact with you
know Sebastian because I know both of
you are from you know the comedy scene
like did you know him you know before
the movie well enough or no didn't know
him the script came to me or like the I
the opportunity came to me the same
traditional way just agent manager
called and said hey this movie was
getting put together there's a role you
could play and uh I did a Zuma Sebastian
and did a couple scenes and uh I was
lucky enough to get the gig yeah yeah I
also really wanted to ask did you get to
keep your Serenity bowls no bring those
home when I the flute is actually my
flute oh really yeah so that flute in
the film I have what college did you go
to I went to Ball State so uh
over in Indiana
never been to Indiana
it's right around the corner is it it's
just like three hours away okay yeah
let's go get some fireworks yeah yeah
have you ever been to a sound Bowl class
no I have not no they're they're
interesting okay yeah okay I know you're
on succession I'm the only one here who
hasn't like you know seen it but I've
been meaning you guys haven't watched
actually I haven't seen it I'm not up
today they don't see they see if they
don't read the newspapers they don't
know anything I was talking about I had
just watched season one okay the day
that we met and I was like yeah I'm
watching this session it's amazing and
you were like okay I gotta watch it but
I didn't but hopelessly
just like my sons
what a funny movie in the loop do you
ever watch that not seen a great movie
Armando iannucci okay
but let me tell you the working on this
movie was as much fun as I've ever had
and working with Robert De Niro was more
fun than I ever had working ever with
another actor right God was he fun to
work with he just he's so funny so much
much more much oh not even a comparison
right uh he's just he's really so great
everything you ever imagined and hoped
and more yeah that's true yeah it was
really fun it was fun working with him
was there any like nerves there very
much one time it did they said I could I
give your interview this is you have to
read a book the director said why don't
you read a book so yeah so they gave me
a prop book I don't know start reading
the book and dinero turns around and
says what book are you reading oh yeah
yeah
but you did great though well I made
something up but oh my God yeah yeah so
it's terrifying but he's he's great and
uh it was the cast was just so funny
everybody in their own way and
it was really fun to work on thank you
and again I I love the movie I can't
wait to see it again so it's awesome wow
thanks man